it's my distinguished pleasure to
introduce yet another incredible speaker
our next speaker is Professor Gary Klein
the gentleman on my right or your left a
couple of things like to say to
introduce him that I wish I could say
more but human seed is PhD or his
master's from Yale PhD from University
of Pennsylvania
he is currently professor of classics in
anthropology at the University on
University in Washington DC
he has managed to achieve three
incredible distinctions the first is he
had managed to conduct 30 consecutive
years of field work as with the seasoned
archaeologists excavated in Megiddo
which is people Armageddon is also cover
II he did somehow while excavating for
30 years is some time to write 16 books
and 100 turtle articles he had also
found time to become a very good teacher
and being a teacher ticlaw work as well
in terms of preparation he has one eye
fountain but I was browsing through the
archaeological Institute of America it's
teaching Awards annual award given and
his name came up about all I must be
good teachers perfect everything else
our cooking and cooking cooking but he
also won the Trachtenberg prize for
Teaching Excellence as well as the
Trachtenberg prize for faculty
scholarship so research and teaching the
only faculty member at GW to go
he is also recently produced of course
the Teaching Company which you can check
out if you're interested and he's a book
that came up recently on the topic of
today which is all a Bronze Age box full
of evolution 77 BC which we'll be
talking about today and you have a
forthcoming book which is a delightful
or I hope I haven't read it but I assume
it will be based upon my conversations
with them a delightful sort of summary
of the field of archaeology in terms of
historical development and major
findings which is worth a tended to be a
sequel to a previous classic and if you
so please join me in welcoming pleasure
bye thank you sir thank you very much
it's wonderful to be here you all having
a good time so far previous speakers
have been great so I have a lot to lift
to live up to yeah well dr. hall is
absolutely amazing so I'm in trepidation
following in his footsteps but we'll see
how I do
anyway it's wonderful to be here it's
nice to be back at Yale I did I got my
masters here in 1984 and near as I could
figure I haven't been back since I was
wandering around last night going wow
this has changed really James but the
halle Graduate Studies is still there so
I felt I felt good anyway we're going to
talk here about the Late Bronze Age and
the collapse of the cities I'll
introduce them to begin with and then
destroy them but I presume this is
familiar to many of you how many of you
teach some aspect of this in your
classes right okay so my scene I can
also us all that stuff right good so
we've got a knowledgeable audience here
so you also won't mind if I go for three
or four hours so fine all right just
stopping when you've had enough all
right so we're going to be concentrating
here on the Late Bronze Age from about
1700 until 1200 BC this is my absolute
favorite period of ancient history if I
could be reincarnated backwards I would
want to be in this particular period I'm
sure I would not survive for about 24 to
48 hours but it would be a lot of fun
while I was there now you see some of
the great powers at the time on this map
I say that they are the g-eight of the
Late Bronze Age there's actually nine
there but who's counting so we've got
over here in Greece we've got the
Minoans in the Mycenaeans we've got the
Hittites up here in Turkey
we've got Mitanni in red we've got
Assyria and Babylonia over here Cypriots
are on Cyprus and then in orange there
we've got the Egyptians coming up the
Nile Valley and into what was then
Canaan so this is what we're going to be
focusing in on and in particular we'll
zoom
and on 1,200 BC and what happened just
after that now those of you that are not
familiar with this period you actually
know more about it than you think
already right Hatshepsut how many have
heard of her the famous female pharaoh
okay Tut Moses the third one of the best
conquerors Egypt ever had my favorite
guy Amenhotep the third I wrote my
master's thesis on him his son Akhenaten
the famous Heretic Pharaoh
King Tut I presume most everybody here
you don't know him you'll be living in
the closet somewhere
alright Ramses the second perhaps the
Pharaoh of the Exodus and then the guy
that we're going to concentrate on
Ramses the third who fights the Sea
Peoples this is also the time period
though of the Battle of Kadesh in about
1279 Trojan War if it took place is
going to be at this time period
somewhere between 1250 and 1175 and also
the Exodus if it took place is going to
be at about this time as well probably
about 1250 BC so lots going on in the
Late Bronze Age in fact it is a I
hesitate to call this but I will a
globalized world system it's not
globalized like we know today but for
that particular period it is globalized
if you talk about something from Italy
on one side to Afghanistan on the other
Turkey down to Egypt that in that area
is a globalized world system such as you
see here this is a social network
diagram that my wife made she does
social network analysis if you're
familiar with the the cocktail party
game the six degrees of Kevin Bacon
right with who is in what movie you can
do the same thing here and that is if
the Egyptians didn't know the Hittites
they knew somebody who knew them so
nobody is more than two or three steps
away from anybody else so it is very
much a small world and that's what you
need to be a globalized world system
back then so for instance we've got in
Greece we've got my Cena in the
Mycenaeans Agamemnon here's the capital
city the type site after which the
Mycenaeans are
are named with the fortification wall
going around
we've got map right there there's my
scene I there in connection to Athens
just to place you there it is on a nice
little mountaintop not the highest
mountaintop in the area but enough that
you can see for about 10 kilometers in
all directions you come in here through
the entrance gate there's the famous
shaft grave circle let's I'll show you
in a minute and you make your way up to
the palace so they're around from about
1700 to 1200 BC it was the famous lion
gate one of the oldest freestanding
sculptures in Europe now it's been
reconstructed like this you know the
heads are not there so archaeologists
have fun playing with putting different
heads on them from time to time
including aliens most recently but never
mind this is a very typical site you
walk up then you've got the big second
pan masonry on your left you've got a
tower on your right and dr. hall was
talking about how the hoplites are
outfitted same sort of thing back here
in the Late Bronze Age you're going to
have your your shield on your left hand
and then your sword in your right hand
doesn't how many people are left-handed
here
yeah sorry back then you're right-handed
no choice right so you've got shield on
your left spear sword and your right as
you're coming up towards the lion gate
here you are going to be protected on
your left side because of your shield
but as you get right up to the entrance
that tower you see it ruined there
you're going to be attacked from your
right you're going to be dead before you
ever get through the gate very standard
for Mycenaean palaces they all have this
system and keep your eye on this right
there it is a slip zone this is actually
is active seismic area so that is
actually one half of an earthquake fault
zone and the archaeologists never knew
that when the seismologist showed up
they started laughing and they're like
what are you laughing at this is a very
serious city they're like they built it
right on top of an earthquake fault zone
and then they went why would anybody do
that and then somebody said I'm from San
Francisco I think we did that too
so so
we'll come back to that keep your eye on
that all right okay so we have the shaft
graves inside which would have looked
like this this is from the earliest
period of the city back in about 1600 BC
where we've got the famous gold masks if
anybody is in the area of Washington DC
go to National Geographic they've got
the Greeks exhibit up right now it's
absolutely amazing 500 objects some of
which have never left Greece before
they've got this one but it's a
facsimile they have one of the other
ones which was real but absolutely
amazing and there was just a three week
series on PBS if you saw it the Greeks
the last one was just now on Tuesday so
absolutely amazing exhibit in Washington
DC my favorite piece inlay dagger the
lion hunt but again this is from the
earliest period of Mycenae if we march
up to the top we get up to the palace
which is going to be there right up
through and functioning until 1200 BC
outer porch inter waiting room and then
the backroom with the King back there
hard to tell what it would have looked
like from the foundations here but if I
tell you that it was completely painted
would that help at all try reimagining
what it might have looked like you're
going to have the walls going up there
plastered and then paint it okay but I
guarantee them no matter what you've
imagined it's nowhere close to reality
that's reality
and also I think qualifies as garish is
the word that comes to mind that's what
it would have looked like all the pieces
none of them were in place they were all
found broken up and lying in the ground
but this is pretty much what it would
have looked like as you walk in there
you're there's a hearth in between you
and the king's palace
so think kind of a Wizard of Oz effect
so you can hear this voice from the back
but you can't really see the King
probably be lit up and it'd still be
dark you'd be smoky there's no windows
the only way anything can get out is
through your your light well up top so
we'd be very dark and smoky and dank in
there I think in comparison the Minoans
on Crete are very different and we've
got the capital city or that one of the
capital let's just call it a capital of
Cano sauce there there's about seven
different palaces on Crete at this time
all owned by the Minoans none of them
with walls around them which has always
caused a problem why wouldn't you have
walls around it so the thinking now is
that maybe the head honcho
- if you will is that canal sauce and
other members of the family are at the
other palaces and that's why they're not
protected because they're not going to
attack each other but this is the
opposite of a Mycenaean Palace this is
open it's light its Airy lots of light
it is integrated into the landscape
these people are at one with the
countryside and they have a love of
plants and animals also so I usually
teach about a real dichotomy between the
Mycenaeans and the Minoans with the
Mycenaeans being very warlike and the
Minoans being a lot more peaceful but
that may be us putting it back on them
they're also into strange things with
bowls right the Minoan bull leapers this
is an actual very small wall painting
showing them doing something with bulls
the women are always white or yellow the
men are always red or browns we've got
two women and one man and either they
are all flipping and you see this in
sequence with her just having landed him
flipping and her
out to jump over or they're more like
like the role of rodeo clowns and
they're distracting the bull while he
leaps over it can't really tell but this
whole idea of leaping over a bull it
imagine like you're in the Olympics and
you're doing the pommel horse except the
pommel horse has horns and it's trying
to kill you all right that's kind of
what's going on right now and in fact if
you type in bull leaping into the
Internet look at YouTube there are
people in Spain that are doing this
today
as part of entertainment so they're
quite good they flip in midair so we've
got the Minoans we've got the Mycenaeans
we also have the Trojans in the Trojan
horse this is not the original this is
the facsimile that was made and put up
at Troy courtesy of Homer of course we
know of the of Troy in the Trojan War
with The Iliad and the Odyssey you're
all familiar with the tale so I won't go
into it but just be aware that the
ancient Greeks didn't know when this had
happened they have 13 different dates
they had suggested finally they settled
on 1184 BC which i think is actually
pretty close it's probably somewhere
between I said earlier 1250 1175 I
probably narrow it down to 1202 1175
somewhere in there Heinrich Schliemann
found Troy that's actually how I got
interested in archaeology and ancient
history to begin with my mother gave me
a book when I was 7 years old called the
walls of Windy Troy it's a biography by
Marjorie Bremer and then when I
graduated from college with a degree in
archaeology and my mother gave me the
same book again so yeah very sweet and
in fact I still have it it's in my
office so and now I teach the seminar to
freshmen on Troy and the Trojan War so
it comes full circle right so anyway
here's Troy 6 which is probably the Troy
of the Trojan War it could be Troy 7 but
you see the massive walls right here I
should mention though that of course not
everybody thinks that the Trojan War
happened my wife in fact does not think
it happens we have arguments at home
over this this is what happens when two
archaeologists marry each other you
argue about the Trojan War
at the same time right so here's Troy
over here on the northwestern coast
we've also got over here blasts coy or
hot to sauce the capital city of the
Hittites they're interacting with
everybody as well you can see here the
mountain pass that's the only way to get
in too hot to sauce we're about an hour
and a half drive east of Ankara at this
point so it's the central Anatolian
plateau that's the only way in they are
also around from about 1700 to 1200 BC
same as the Minoans Mycenaeans their
city's only captured twice in their
entire history because it was so well
protected all right so here it is
there's the plan on a photograph and you
can see even if you make it in then
you've got to go up against their
fortifications and it gets awfully cold
and snowy in the winter there and they
don't have things like olives so they
have to trade for olive oil they have
their own Lion Gate which looks a little
different from the Mycenaean one these
look more like seals to me than lions
right but the famous seal gate doesn't
quite work we don't know which way the
influences go the Hittites and the
Mycenaeans are definitely influencing
each other but we don't know which way
the influences are going and then we've
got us the site of Gaara on the north
coast of Syria I'm not actually sure if
it exists anymore since it's in the
middle of a Syrian Syrian civil war and
other things but well the French
excavated it from about the 1920s on now
you can see the town right here it turns
out to be a very important international
trading center during the Late Bronze
Age and it's particularly important for
us because there have been a number of
archives found so we've actually got the
written texts and there is now a whole
cottage industry of ogre it extend ease
tablets they've got historical records
they've got letters between Kings
letters from vassals they've also got
myths epics love poems you name it
they've got everything written the only
thing is you have to be able to read
Booga Riddick which I can't but others
can so
so this gives us an insight because in
among these texts they talk about things
going along merrily right up until the
end when that just collapses so
everything's to me seems to be okay it's
not a gradual decline it's very very
very sudden so what we've got the
hallmark of this whole period we're in
the Bronze Age in fact the Bronze Age as
a whole goes from 3000 BC to 1000 BC
we're in the Late Bronze Age which as I
said is 1700 to 1200 BC the way you make
bronze as I've got up here on the slide
is 10 plus copper 90% copper 10% tin you
do those you've got yourself bronze if
you don't have 10 you can use arsenic I
don't recommend it you're not going to
live very long but you could use arsenic
if you need to now the copper is not a
problem
copper is coming from Cyprus in fact
that's where the name comes from Chios
means copper the tin is another bit of a
problem though there's a little bit of
tin down here in Turkey
there's also 10 in Cornwall and they may
have been going from time to time to get
it there but the vast majority of the
tin in the ancient world at that time is
coming from off the map here in
Afghanistan specifically the Badakhshan
region in fact it's not just tin that
comes from there anybody here have any
lapis lazuli jewelry okay
lapis also comes from that area and they
are trading for it so this is some of
the raw materials and the ten is going
to come all the way across from
Afghanistan to the Aegean and perhaps
beyond so in fact we have a letter from
the site of Mari which is right there on
the Euphrates River and what is Syria
today it's a letter that dates to a
little after 1800 BC so almost just
before the start of our period and in
this text which I know is too small you
can't read it so I'll read it to you it
says one on a third Mina of 10 to the
cafetorium now calf tour is their name
for Crete so one and a third Mina of ten
to the Minoan from Crete a third of a
Mena of ten to the interpreter
of the chief merchant of the CAF
torian's in ugarit so this is a letter
at Mari it's talking about ogre it and
it's talking about ten coming from
Afghanistan and there is a guy
apparently who's an interpreter who is
able to speak both Minoan and Akkadian
and is translating for them so we know
that the ten is coming to Mari then to
agar it and then over to Crete and
onwards so this is long-distance trade
imagine if it's cut at any point you're
going to be in trouble for your ten and
if you're in trouble for your ten you're
in trouble for your bronze and that
seems to be part of what happens round
about 1200 BC is that these trade routes
are probably cut now in terms of how
important tin was at the time the best
analogy I can make is what my friend
Carol Bell did she's a academic over in
Britain and she said tend to them was
like oil to us today and that getting
tin concerned the Egyptian pharaoh and
the hittite king just as much as getting
oil concerns the u.s. president today
and i think that's probably the best
analogy so they are trading 2010 they
are trading lapis lazuli they are also
trading finished goods and in these mari
letters which again date to about 1800
bc one letter for example says a
cafetorium weapon so that's a Minoan
weapon coming from Crete the top on the
base are covered with gold its top is
encrusted with lapis lazuli so it would
have looked something like this this
isn't actually it this is from the death
pits of or dating to about 2500 BC but
it must have looked similar with the
gold and the lapis lastly I don't know
about you but I want one of these I just
I just want one of these but we've also
got a text that talks about probably my
my favorite incident in ancient history
it says one pair of leather shoes and
the cafetorium style so Minoan shoes and
if you've been to how many people have
been to Crete
we'll create you Manoa its sandals
basically there's an yah makes boots but
most everybody else makes leather
sandals so parallel the shoes in the
cafetorium style which to the palace of
Hammurabi king of Babylon and yes that
is the Hammurabi and eye for an eye a
tooth for a tooth black tea lemon
official carried but which were returned
so somebody is sending Minoan sandals
all the way to Babylon and giving them
to Hammurabi and he says thanks but no
thanks and returns them I've never
understood that so were they to last
millennium were they too small now you
know the law Code of Hammurabi has got
272 laws in it and I frequently teach my
students at least the first couple of
them in my intro class but then one day
for fun I just said here's an English
translation go through and tell me the
penalty for returning shoes or sandals
and they came back kind of crestfallen
they said there's no penalty there's no
law I said exactly he got away with it
but still I don't know you got something
coming all the way from Crete wouldn't
you have said here these don't fit me
but they'll fit you
I mean rege if thing doesn't work anyway
so the point is that they're sending
around finished objects along with the
raw materials and I would argue along
with both of those sets of goods also
the ideas are coming so they're coming
along so for instance epic of gilgamesh
The Iliad The Odyssey they're all
portions that are vaguely similar
everybody goes down to the underworld
this that and the other I think those
stories are coming with the trade goods
and here the importance are the people
that are Manning the boats right dr.
Hall just talked about how many people
were in a trireme and all that well you
don't quite have that many on a Late
Bronze Age boat but you still do have an
entire crew and when the officials are
up at the palace doing the diplomatic
negotiations and whatever they're doing
the crewmen are getting drunk in the
bars and the ends waiting to go back
home and they're like hey I got a story
for you and I think they're swapping
tails and they're swapping ideas and so
I think that's in part
something that we've overlooked the
transmission of ideas at the lower
levels of society just the ordinary
people who are there you know for some
other reason are then swapping these
stories I think that's how we get things
like the myth of Kumar be from the
hittites looking a lot like he see it's
works I think that's how it's getting
there so I wouldn't discount the
ordinary people and we do know that
there are such trade embassies and other
things diplomatic here's hot Shep suit
for example at her mortuary temple we
know that she sends an embassy to point
she's not the first to do so from Egypt
and she will not be the last but she
gives us the best representation of what
is being brought back from point she
even tells us the queen of punts her
name is Ettie so we know that they've
got people going back and forth our
manger our major problem was we didn't
know where point was until recently just
a couple of years ago in the British
Museum they analyze some baboon mummies
and found out that they most closely
resemble in the DNA on other things to
ethiopia and eritrea which actually was
one of the suggestions it was a retro
Ethiopia and Yemen were the main
candidates for point so now we can say
pretty much for sure Ethiopia Eritrea
that is where point is so imagine the
Egyptians sending trade down there but
they're also trading with people from
the Aegean this is the tomb of Rick
Marais well vizier to top moses the
third and hatshepsut and on the walls of
his tomb he's got Minoans painted
bringing gifts actually one of them is
repainted and they're thinking maybe
this is when Mycenaeans take over from
Minoans but who knows Aegean people
let's just put it that way they're
trading with the Aegean here's another
one that guy carrying a Bulls head is
definitely a Minoan no no two ways about
it
so we've got the Egyptians sending out
diplomatic embassies and trade missions
all over the place at this time another
one to the Aegean my favorite there's
colossi of memnon the mortuary temple of
Amenhotep the third this is dating to a
bell
you know 13 60 BC the mortuary temple is
completely gone
it was stolen by the other pharaohs and
to build their temples right ready-made
blocks but if you go back there and into
the weeds they found at one point they
had found five statue bases and it's now
up to about 40 because of the renewed
excavations there
each of these statue bases which is
about 10 feet tall would have been the
statue so slightly over life-size they
have a list of names on the base that
represent the world is known to the
Egyptians in the Late Bronze Age this
particular one lists names from Greece
it's never been seen before it will
never be seen again these two over here
are Tenaya and KEF to you which are the
egyptian names for mainland Greece
that's Tenaya and KEF to you it's like
cuffed or that's Crete so you've got
mainland Greece and Crete here and then
over on this side and around you've got
14 other names and these are names like
I said that have never been seen before
amny sauce Festus cadonia Mycenae dick
take arrows a Croma thana Napoli ankara
illios Cano sauce and then amny sauce
again this looks to me like a
geographical itinerary and in fact if
you go to Greece at most of the sites
that are listed on that statue base you
actually have objects of Amenhotep the
third or his wife Queen T at those of
gian sites so here is a finance plaque
there's about 11 of them at Mycenae with
Amenhotep netra nephron imatra that's
Amenhotep the third these type of
Egyptian plaques are not found anywhere
else in the world outside of Egypt
except Mycenae there's something special
that went on there
so I actually think that we've got as I
said a geographical itinerary where
they're going up to Crete and visiting
the Minoans who they've known for quite
a while then they continue on to the
Mycenaean so at this point are kind of
up starts in the 14th century then they
come back down to Crete and then back to
Egypt and I think that's why I'm new
sauce is on there twice
so the first place you get to when
you're coming up from Crete you're like
oh thank God everybody out use the
bathroom I'm going to get a coffee rest
stop right then you go around the Aegean
and then you come back and you're like
okay we're back at m2 sauce last stop
everybody empty your bladder get your
coffee now we're headed for Egypt right
so it's a round trip this is what I
think now I don't think I'm in hotel the
third himself went I think this is some
sort of diplomatic or trade embassy that
is going there and in fact we have very
good evidence that such things we're
going on this is the gulab Arun ship
that sank off the coast of Turkey in
about 1300 BC so a little after the time
of Amenhotep the third this is from
National Geographic and what you see up
top is an Egyptian tomb painting much
like we had it recommends tomb and then
the bottom is the reconstruction of what
the ship would have looked like right so
it goes down at about 1300 BC was found
in 1982 they did something like 20,000
dives in a dozen years there and took
pictures of everything most of the cargo
is copper ingots like raw copper from
Cyprus each of the weighing about 60
pounds there are more than 300 ingots on
this shipwreck then there's also these
blocks of stone with a hole in each one
and we know what those are they're
running the length of the keel so
they're being used as ballast for most
of the time but then
who actually stone anchors yeah so as
your anchor gets stuck you're like and
you cut the rope and then you pull up
another one in the meantime they're
being used as ballast we have these
types of stone anchors at sites in
Cyprus for example but we've never
actually found them before in situ in an
ancient ship so as I said there's more
than 300 of these oxide ingots as we
call them they look like if you
slaughtered an ox and chopped off the
head and then you just had the legs it's
in four and you can actually carry these
quite easily those 300 is make about ten
tonnes of copper there's also a ton of
tin on the wreck so if you put those
together you've got yourselves 11 tonnes
of bronze so when this ship went down
somebody lost a fortune and actually
suspect that somebody must have lost a
kingdom or a war also because this
amount of copper and tin as George bass
the guy that was excavating this once
said you could outfit an army of 300
people with swords shields helmets even
Greaves the whole shebang so this is
enough to outfit 300 men so there's part
of the tin there's a tin ingot right
there another so there's a ton also got
terebinth resin on board which is from
the pistachio tree you use this in
making perfume there's a ton of that on
board ivory the Tusk is from an elephant
the other two the incisor and canine are
from hippo and this actually made
everybody go back to the museum's
because we had just thought all the
ivory was from elephant turns out about
90% in the bronze ages from hippo and
they're like but there aren't any hippos
in Israel Lebanon Syria now they're like
yep
now you know why exactly right so lots
of raw ivory they're some of my
favorites up here also ingots of raw
material anyway hazard a guess what
material we're looking at there it's not
lapis but it's a replacement for it it's
glass it's raw glass in this case
they're colored with cobalt so they're
blue but yeah exactly and that's why
glass is invented in part to replace
expensive stone like lapis lazuli
but in addition to the blue we've also
got pink ones yellow ones brown ones
we've got all kinds they've got about
150 of these I think maybe a little bit
less on board and then down here
finished cargo this is actually from
Cyprus and Cyril Palestine and they were
found in a huge jar which originally
they thought would have held fresh water
and been up on the deck turns out it was
a China barrel when they tipped it over
trying to pick it up all this spilled
out so you've got raw materials and
finished goods and it looks like this
ship is heading towards Greece because
the one thing you don't have in any of
this are brand new stuff from the
Minoans or Mycenaeans you do have some
used pottery which looks like it belongs
to the crew but you don't have finished
goods so it looks like this is all stuff
from the Near East being sent to Greece
on the return home or just the return
trip you would have probably packed full
Minoan and Mycenaean stuff taking it to
Egypt in the Near East but this is going
to Greece at this point so this is the
route they thought it went round and
round and round and round I'm not so
sure about that I actually think this
might be a ship sent for from one King
to another as a royal gift because
there's a couple of objects on there
that are only used by Kings these
drinking vessels called B brew so I'm
not sure I agree with George bass and I
might suggest an alternative that it's
straight one way or the other but we
also suggested my co-director Acharya
and I we published an article in about
2007 suggesting that the other Brewin
ship was actually on a shopping trip and
it was from Greece to the Near East
because all the
materials match things that have
workshops at places like Pylos and my
CNI so somebody could say look we're
pretty much out of tin we're out of
copper we're out of glass we need some
of that turbans resin stuff so can
somebody go to the Near East and get it
and while you're out get some milk and
sugar too right but on the way back it's
sank so and it's definitely possible
because we've got sets of weights from
both sides so I put that out there as a
possibility and we've also got textual
evidence from just a little bit later
this is from lugar one of the merchants
in North Syria guy named Sonora know and
it says in the text from the present day
I'm a stammers son of Nik Mehta
king of Wu Garrett exempts in Iran Oh
son of Seguin ooh I really wanted to
name my son this but my wife objected I
don't know why I'm like he'll be the
only sinner on who in the classroom Hey
no so this guy sinner Ando is the
merchant his grain his beer has olive
oil to the palace he shall not deliver
his ship is exempt when it arrives from
Crete so you've got a guy in North Syria
sending a private merchant sending a
ship to Crete bringing back grain olive
oil and beer and when he gets back he
doesn't have to pay taxes on it
so I think this is actually the first
corporate tax exemption in history that
we've got right so it shows how
interconnected that everybody is at this
time okay so everybody is merrily going
along like this from it's it takes a
little while to get started but by say
1500 this is going on so 1,500 1,400
1,300 diplomacy reciprocity trade
everybody is happily interacting with
absolutely everybody else round about
1200 BC there's a little chaos
interjected here and one by one each of
the civilization winks out until you're
left just with Egypt it's the only one
really left standing and even they are
so weakened that this is a Pyrrhic
victory right they'll never be as great
as they were back in the New Kingdom
period of time at King Tut and all that
yes exactly right so Egypt always is
under somebody else's thumb so this is
what's happened there is a collapse
round about 1200 BC I actually think it
takes place a little bit later it's
actually a continuous it's like a
systems collapse which we will get to
but basically everybody and everything
we just talked about goes away that's it
so it is a huge collapse it is ginormous
as my kids would say I would say that
the world doesn't see such an enormous
collapse again until the Romans fall
right and that's going to be 1,500 years
later so the big question is what caused
this what could bring everything to a
screeching halt all at the same time
what could cause these cities like my
scene I can also as hot Rosasco guard to
all simply end and if they ended that
suddenly could have happened to us and
that's why I think that studying this
particular period which is you know
3,200 years ago is not as irrelevant as
some people might think I think it does
hold some lessons perhaps for us without
pushing it a little bit too much if we
can see what led to their collapse and
then see if we've got anything around
today we might go huh maybe we should
try avoiding that kind of stuff so the
problem is we don't actually know what
happens it always used to be blamed on
the sea peoples and they come through
according the Egyptians they come
through twice they come through and 1207
and they come through in eleven seventy
seven right that's where the title of my
book comes from is eleven seventy seven
for the second wave now even that is not
quite accurate because you know the
Egyptologists keep changing the
chronology so it's actually more
accurate to say they come through in the
fifth year Merneptah and the eighth year
of Ramses the third so
we know about them from the wall relief
that rams is the third leaves us at
medinet habu this was found a very long
time ago so Gaston Maspero a french
egyptologist already by the 1860s had
said ìlook the sea peoples must be
responsible for the collapse and by
about 1901 that was the theory
so whenever anybody went and excavated a
site that was destroyed at about this
time they said oh it must be the sea
peoples but that's kind of working
backwards that's finding a theory and
then fitting your facts to it and so the
sea peoples now in kind of revisionist
history are no longer at least according
to me responsible for as much
destruction as we thought I do think
that they're there but I think in some
cases they're as much victims as they
were oppressors and I'll show you that
in just a moment but first as a sample
Ramses the third in urate tells us the
foreign countries made a conspiracy in
their islands all at once the lands were
removed and scattered in the fray no
land could stand before their arms from
Koch a code a car commercial art sua and
Alaska on now we know where those are
right hot eh those are the Hittites up
in Turkey Cote is where turkey meets
Syria kharkom ash is in the same area
arts with o is back on the western coast
of Turkey over by Troy Elijah is the
ancient name for Cyprus but basically we
can see that they're sweeping from west
to east they're coming across Greece and
Turkey and Cyprus and then a camp was
set up in one place in a more that's by
who Garrett and North Syria and then
they come down to Egypt they were coming
forward all the flame was prepared
before them and then he tells us who
they are he doesn't actually call them
the sea peoples that's our name for them
he actually tells us the individual
groups Paulette to jackar shekel s
denyen and Wes lands United so he
actually names them and in fact
Merneptah 30 years earlier had named a
slightly different group so all told
there's about nine groups that come on
in but Ramses tells us that he defeated
they see people's lose both times I
overthrew those who invaded from their
lands I slew the denyen who are in their
Isles the two Jecker and the Poulet were
made ashes shardana and the Wes of the
sea they were made as those that exist
not and so on so in the end like I say
Egypt won but it was a Pyrrhic victory
on the way everybody else lost so one of
our big questions is who exactly are
these people
well Ramses shows us them these are
pictures of the sea peoples and so for
instance if you want to go dressed up as
a sea person for Halloween you can do so
because you know what they look like
it's actually easier though just cut out
like the letter C 50 times and put it on
you right and that way when somebody
says what are you can say I'm a sea
person right graduate school it worked
they won yeah yeah bad joke I know but
so here they are sardonic checklist
ejector Dania and Wes pull si people
have been playing linguistic games with
these guys for a very very long time
so in trying to figure out where they
come from anybody think of anything in
the Mediterranean that has consonants
like s Rd and Sardinia absolutely people
have suggested they come from Sardinia
what about shekel s anything with an S
and a K and an L or maybe a C and an L
Sicily right people have suggested
Sicily - jackar might be somewhere
around Troy denyen people want these to
be the de Naughton of Homer I can memnon
on those guys Wes they're not so sure
about polis at though even jean-francois
Champollion the guy who deciphered
Egyptian hieroglyphics he had already
said the pleasant were listings and in
fact the Bible says the Philistines come
from Crete so maybe that works maybe it
doesn't so out of all of these we're not
really sure about any except the pole
essa and in and indeed some people have
said rather than coming from these areas
they might have gone there after they
were defeated so maybe they gave their
name to Sardinia afterward I happen to
think they came
from the west and went east because
Ramsey says he settled them in his
strongholds in Egypt and up into Israel
where Tel d'Or is called a sickle town
which is one of these guys so I think
that they may well have come from here
and then settled over in the East and
one of the reasons I say that is because
we know the Philistines from areas of
Israel and Lebanon and their pottery
looks like Mycenaean pottery but made
with local clay that's what we call
degenerate Mycenaean it looks like
Mycenaeans from Greece picked up move
over to the Near East keep making their
pottery but now they're making with
local clay that's not as good so I think
that the Philistines are my snails but
who have moved to the Near East and that
would fit as part of this yeah now
notice though as part of the
inscriptions Ramsey shows us this
picture here's a drawing of it here
these are not Viking raiders these are
not macho men just out to kill and
plunder these are people moving with
their entire families you see the wives
and the kids and the entire household
goods on a cart pulled by oxen this is a
mass migration they are moving because
they have to so I would say this is like
the Dust Bowl in the 1930s people moving
from Oklahoma to Texas in California
that's what we're looking at here so
what causes such a migration you don't
move unless you have to so something is
causing it they have to move so if it's
not the Sea Peoples and I think that's
too simple then what is it but people
used to say oh there was a drought then
there was famine then the sea peoples
moved and then they cut the trade routes
and then there was collapse but you know
I think things are usually much more
complicated that may have been part of
it but that wasn't the whole thing so
what really happened that's what we want
to spend the rest of the time on let's
see we're at yeah we've got time so if
the sea peoples are not the boogeyman
they used to be then what might have
happened people have suggested droughts
they've suggested famine they suggested
invaders they've suggested earthquakes
which of these do I like I like them all
I think everything happened I think this
was not a good time to be alive
I think this was a perfect storm of the
absolute worst catastrophes all coming
at the same time because you can survive
a drought at least some people can you
can survive a famine
some people will invaders some people
survive earthquakes some will survive
what if they come one after the other
after the other one on top of another
you get a multiplier effect and after
like the third one you're like alright I
give up we're dead right so I think what
we've got is a perfect storm here let me
show you what I mean
drought this is actually not a new
suggestion Reese carpenter from Bryn
Mawr suggested it in the 1960s he said
the Mycenaeans ended because of drought
but he didn't have proof for it it was
just a hypothesis now we've got the
proof in the last five years the proof
has come up there is a site near Garrett
called Gabala and county uski a french
scholar led a team there that looked at
cores from dried-up lakes and in the
cores they looked at the pollen and the
pollen is showing that there was what he
calls a dry event in other words a
drought it lasted for about 300 years
from the late 13th early 12th centuries
right down to the 9th century in other
words the Dark Ages in Greece this is
that period so he has evidence that the
pollens suggest drier climatic changes
and conditions went over to Cyprus did
the same thing 2013 at Hollis Alton
techy from the dried-up lagoon there
same thing major environmental changes
from 1,200 to 850 BC everything became
dryer so drought climate change if you
will
caused by mother nature they're not
driving SUVs back then right but Mother
Nature can do it just as well and then
Lee Drake 2012 looked at stuff from
Israel to Turkey to Greece to Italy came
up with at least three different other
things that all suggest a drier climate
including a drop in the temperature of
the surface of the sea if that happens
you're going to get less rain on the
mainland so maybe we do have a drought
after all hey
says this starts between 1250 and 1197
BC right in this particular case just a
word of warning to any of you active on
Facebook and of your students active on
Facebook right
I liked leaves articles so much that I
wanted to send them a little note saying
I don't usually do that but I'm like
this was a great article in the journal
of archaeological science so I googled
Brandon Lee Drake and it came up it says
you are friends on Facebook like really
so I sent them an email and I'm like I
don't actually remember knowing you but
I really liked your article hero
packages at Eric we dug at Megiddo in
2006 like no that was a guy named Ali
Drake he says yeah that's me I published
with Brandon my middle names Lee I go by
Lee I'm like so a word of warning you
may know people that you don't even
think you know right and then in Israel
Finkelstein definite long route and
Thomas lit from Germany they did the
same thing in the Sea of Galilee and the
Dead Sea they took coring samples and
the pollen there also indicates a severe
drought from 1250 to 1100 BC so that's a
little bit of a shorter period it's only
150 years but so now we've got
scientific evidence for drought in North
Syria Israel Cyprus Greece I say that's
pretty much the Mediterranean right so I
think we can say that there's drought of
course each time one of these
publications came out the media got
ahold of it New York Times LA Times
National Geographic
archeology New York Post got into it
of course they added in globalization
for good matter to alright so everybody
got all excited about Late Bronze Age
and drought and all that finally great
way you've been finally and then finally
yes nicely course that's that's my alarm
don't you all have any other Jones's
your alarm so I know I've got about ten
minutes left so right remember the NASA
funded study that came out a couple
years ago that said we were going to
decline in a couple of decades then it
turned out it wasn't NASA funded and all
that right at that point I wrote an
op-ed for the Huffington Post going
collapse of civilizations it's
complicated because it is indeed
complicated so drought equals famine
often sure do we have any evidence for
that well that's where a guard comes in
and those archives I mentioned because
even if there's famine we don't have
like mass graves at this time but what
we do have is textual evidence here is
one text from the house of a merchant
called or tainu which is from about
eleven eighty five BC and he says
there's famine in our house we'll all
die of hunger if you don't quickly
arrive here we ourselves will die of
hunger you will not see a living soul
from your land so famine I think so
but others here's a letter from the king
of Ooo guard to somebody else here with
me plenty has become famine so I don't
think the texts lie here these guys are
suffering even up from the Hittites in
Turkey there's from the king do you not
know there was a famine in the midst of
my land it's a matter of life and death
alright so they've got droughts and
they've got famine not too surprising
the two usually go hand-in-hand
what about invaders and what about
internal rebellion can be very difficult
to tell these apart because you end up
with simply a destruction level you
don't often know who did it so in one
case we know that the king of Ooo Gaara
is right into the king of Cyprus and you
say
my father now the ships of the enemy
have come they've been setting fire to
my cities and have darn harm to my land
now if any other ships come please let
me know so in this case we know that
this is foreign invaders and in fact
this text I was always taught when I was
in college in grad school that this was
in a kiln in the palace at jugar it
being baked before it was sent to Cyprus
but that the invaders had come and set
fire to the city before it could be sent
a very dramatic tale too good to be true
turns out upon reanalysis that this was
not in a kiln it was in a basket that
had fallen from the second floor and
turned upside down leaving a kiln shape
when the basket disintegrated and it's
in there with about seventy other
tablets so we still do know that there
are invaders but we don't know if it's
from the last days or maybe from that
first wave back in 1207 but still here
we know we've got invaders and another
one from lugar this one we know is from
the last days when your messenger
arrived the army was already humiliated
the city was sacked our food and the
threshing floors was burnt the vineyards
were also destroyed our city of sacked
may you know it may you know it so again
definite invaders here same thing with
Connie uski when he was at Gabala they
actually had a destruction layer which
he promptly said is the Sea Peoples and
the rest of us promptly said maybe not
it's a destruction but what says sea
people she's like well that's when they
were here like yeah but that doesn't
mean this is them so yes no I give you
hot sore as probably the best example
Canaanite hot sore in modern Israel
we know it's destroyed in about 1200 BC
because we've got the burnt mud bricks
they're fired red and black in a final
destruction the two co-directors are
split though as to who did it
one Amnon ben-tor says it wasn't
Egyptians because they're Egyptian
statues that are mutilated in the
destruction and Egyptians would never
have mutilated such statues it's not
Canaanites because same thing there are
Canaanite mutilated statues they
wouldn't have done it so maybe
Israelites maybe Sea Peoples he says
this is too far inland
see people's which I disagree with so
for him that leaves Israelites which
means you get to do the Bible because
hot sore is mentioned as destroyed in
the Bible so he wants it to be
Israelites but his co-director Sharon
Zuckerman who just passed away about a
year ago she said I'm not wait a minute
what is burnt at our site and he says
palaces temples and she's like yeah what
else and he says no that's it palaces
and temples and she's like well if you
have an internal rebellion if you're 99%
rise up against the 1% they're going to
burn the temples and the palaces but not
their own houses not their own workshops
and he's like what are you saying it's
just that I think it's an internal
rebellion I think when they have a
famine and a drought they rise up you
can't tell so if the two co directors of
the site can't decide who destroyed
their site I don't know how we're going
to decide so maybe invaders maybe
internal rebellion but maybe earthquakes
I'm going to go through this quickly but
let me just say that it's very tough to
tell the destruction caused by an
earthquake from a destruction caused by
humans the one major difference is you
won't have weapons if it's an earthquake
right so for example this all the
earthquakes that have happened in turkey
in the last 100 years and if you put
them on top of the cities that are
destroyed at 1200 you notice most of the
cities are in an active seismic fault
zone so in fact there's all the fault
lines and they're running across our
entire area so I think some of the
destructions are caused by earthquakes
rather than by humans so remember that
slip zone I showed you at my scene I my
scene is destroyed by an earthquake
right at about this time period at
nearby Teheran so actually this is still
my scene I this young let me see that
rock there that was in her head she had
sheltered in place she had sheltered in
a doorway which was usually the safest
place in the earthquake in this case the
doorway came down slammed in her head
killed her instantly
so that is in my scene I victim at
nearby tear ins which is just about 10
kilometers away we've got the bones
woman and child that were killed by a
collapsing wall Troy that's not supposed
to look like that that's what happens
when you have an earthquake here's my
picture from last August right that is
what happens when an earthquake tilts
and indeed Troy 6 looks like it's
destroyed by an earthquake and then back
into gar with all of our tablets that
wall is not supposed to look like that
that's what happens when you have an
earthquake so there are a series of
earthquakes that happen between about
1225 and 1175 and then cutting of the
trade routes we've already talked about
if you're 10 and you're copper if that's
cut off at any point you're in real
trouble and in fact that may have been
why they went to it's probably why they
went to iron afterward if you can't get
the tin you can't make bronze you're
going to go to iron and it turns out
that iron is actually better anyway
but be aware they've already been using
iron in the Bronze Age and they still
use bronze in the Iron Age in fact King
Tut's one of those daggers you read
about that a couple weeks ago it said
King Tut has an alien dagger
yeah the irons from a meteor but still
so they did know iron back then so I
think we've got cutting of the trade
routes back then also so if I can sum up
then let me give you three points that I
think you will all agree with there'll
be no argument would you agree that
there are a number of separate
civilizations at this time nice and
man's Assyrians Babylonians Hittites all
that right they are independent but
they're interacting right pretty obvious
everybody agrees all right it's also
clear that many of the cities the ones
we've talked about and others were
destroyed at this time they come to an
end around about eleven seventy seven
again no disagreement right everything
goes kaput right but we have no proof as
to what caused this we still don't know
the answer right everybody agrees with
that so what have we gonna do here I've
been talking for an hour or so and I
don't have a promised answer which
everybody reads my book they get pissed
off about that too I'm like I don't have
an answer because there isn't an answer
because it's still a question that we're
investigating so all of these I think
are a possibility however people still
use this simplistic drought to famine to
move in to see people's - cutting a
trade route to collapse I heard that at
our academic conference last November
I'm like no it's not that serious that
that simple it's much much messier so
what I think we've got droughts famine
earthquakes invaders rebellions yes all
of them it is all together as I said and
we are so interlinked back then they are
so interdependent they are not
self-sufficient that when one went down
they all went down just like dominoes so
when the Mycenaeans go down it affects
the Hittites which affects the Cypriots
which affects the Egyptians so this is
part of the problem with being so
intertwined back then but it's also what
we call a systems collapse literally the
entire system collapsed it's not the
only place it's not the only time this
happens elsewhere and elsewhen but the
hallmarks central administration
collapses traditional elite go away
centralized economy collapses and you
have population shifts and population
decline and again we see this in other
places and in other time periods
it also takes up to a century for this
to all happen so while I used 1177 as
kind of the linchpin or the hallmark I'm
fully aware that it didn't all happen
that year it takes like I said up to a
century so at one part in the book I
said something like life in 1200 was
different from life in 1100 and very
different from life in 1000 BC and that
was when my publisher said that's too
long a title it won't fit on the cover
seriously what I would say is 1177 is to
the fall of the Bronze Age s 476 is to
the fall of the Roman Empire we all know
the Roman Empire did not fall in 476 but
that's the date that you drum into the
students if you remember any date
remember 476 same thing here I want to
make 1177 the date that people remember
for the end of the Late Bronze Age but
the other takeaway is what can we learn
from this and I already kind of hinted
at this are we currently facing a
similar situation do we have climate
change
well most would argue yes we could argue
about that for the rest of the afternoon
but most would say yes famines and
droughts various parts of the world yes
earthquakes rebellions I think the only
thing we're missing with the Sea Peoples
and in fact I would now argue that Isis
are the sea peoples because they are
busy destroying all the ancient
antiquities and all that on the other
hand you could say that the refugees in
Europe are the sea peoples yeah so it
could it depends are they the victims or
the oppressors Central American refugees
coming over whether is the absolutely
right so I actually think we've got all
the same things and in fact recent news
ripped from the headlines in the last
like two three years from the Middle
East in the Mediterranean Greece's
economy is tanked there's internal
rebellions in Libya Egypt and Syria
Outsiders and foreign warriors Turkey is
afraid it's going to become involved
Israel's afraid of that
Jordan's graduate with refugees today
Iran bellicose and threatening Iraq is
in turmoil if we had headlines from the
Middle East from 1200 BC pretty much the
same thing
so the question is what are we going to
do about it I mostly look at ancient
history I don't look ahead so I leave it
to other people to figure it out but
what I would say is one of the main
differences is that we've got obviously
better technology now but we're also
aware of what's happening so when the
Hittites had a drought they probably
didn't even realize if we're quite a
while and then they couldn't figure out
what to do about it
you know pray to the storm god or
something now we can figure out what to
do about it the thing is we have to
actually first admit that we've got a
problem and it's kind of the thing where
I think if you think you've got a
problem and you go to solve it and it
turns out you didn't have a problem what
have you lost but if you did have a
problem then you've gone some way to
fixing it so part of me thinks that
we've got some of the same problems that
they had back in 1200 I'm optimistic
until they realize that every
civilization up until now has fallen and
there's no reason why we would be left
out of that so it may be a matter of
when rather than if but I don't think
we're quite there yet at the same time
looking at what happened to 1200 BC does
give me pause and with that I thank you